qu'est ce qu'on attendait d'eux plus de
bolton araud c'est un président qui est
xénophobe homophobe misogyne
à partir de ce moment là c'est comme si
demain on est étonné des propos d'eric
zemmour on dirait incroyable écouter ce
que dit eric zemmour c'est le quotidien
d'eric zemmour il ne faut pas être
choqué c'est son fond de commerce après
zidane a bu mais en revanche ce qui est
gênant c'est que on donne beaucoup de
leçons aux autres
mais j'aimerais qu'on balaie un peu
devant notre porte souvenez-vous d une
nauséabonde de charlie hebdo sur madame
macron justement juste avant elle avait
défendu déjà sa maman après la
publication en revanche pour eric
naulleau c'est de l'humour donc d'abord
de grivel contrit d'abord nos poubelles
avant de s'occuper talent mais c'est
humain et sur le plan d'égalité de
choses sans rien avoir à présent la
république est un journal satirique ah
bah oui comme c'est charlie hebdo qui a
l'immunité médiatique finalement tout
est formidable sudiste de l'ethnie
charlie l'autre vers l'est ce je vois ça
je trouve ça nauséabond de même façon
qu'on traite les femmes ici alors comme
des objets on vous a vu la tête de
bolton arrow c'est lui qui donne des
leçons de physique franchement quand un
homme aux cheveux blancs ont dit c'est
sympa c'est poivre et sel
enfin une femme qui a des cheveux blancs
elle se néglige un homme qui a du bit
c'est un bon vivant
une femme elle se néglige un homme qui a
des maîtresses c'est un charmeur une
femme c'est une [ __ ]
donc c'est la double problème il est là
c'est dans la différenciation entre le
traitement des hommes et traitement des
femmes mais c'est la reine avec le
brésil on a des les mêmes problèmes ici
donc occuper un peu d'accord
alors justement rapport